[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir miss france
merci d'être là alors il sera sur les
treize heureux de voir nous avait donc
été élu donc c'était samedi soir sur tf1
si on peut être sur place et fait un
petit peu de respect pourrissement s'il
vous plaît
miss france merci d'être là est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter pour les
français qui ne vous connaissent pas oui
bonjour déjà je m'appelle chicha
d'accord je suis là la cousine du
chouchou et le contenu sur le nom depuis
le leem de camille bissière d'accord il
va me sert bien sûr mes amis de sierre
oui oui vous êtes miss quoi mais c'est
possible et vous avez vous savez des
passions chicha nu et les fruits des
fruits c'est ma passion papaye goyave
noix de coco et les fruits dans des
yaourts et sa j'adore
[Applaudissements]
après je manger les fruits ça dégouline
comme ça je fais des photos tenue dans
ma cuisine en soi qui a plu à des ados
sont lourds et à la culture c'est
important pour une masse et quels sont
vos goûts en peinture vous êtes plutôt
monnaies ou rembrandt rembrandt et
j'aime bien ouais parce que ma mère elle
avait une machine à laver rembrandt en
plus et mieux qu'aux arts paul bret
d'accord mais en faveur d'un témoin au
tout puissant vous coûter faire quoi
pour changer le monde parce que
maintenant votre parole va compter déjà
je n'aime pas ce journal le monde je
n'aime pas moi je préfère téléphone jeu
télé 7 jours j'aime bien d'accord très
bien mais s'il en faut pour changer le
monde
j'enlèverai des pages une question
basique que tout le monde se pose donc
préféré dans souple est là c'est
important parce que les français ont
besoin de savoir
vous préférez miss france la guerre ou
la paix la guerre ou la paix c'est pas
facile
by année je vais dire la guerre pour
l'ambiance les pétards
[Rires]
et le petit fils qui
dépister poil c'est ça le côté festif
bien c'est mal quoi je sers bien nous
avons envie de faire quoi après miss
france les papiers et charles la normale
mandat
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jean rendez vous à la préfecture du tarn
avec 18
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rendez vous à la préfecture je vais
faire toutes les cartes la carte vitale
pour le docteur la carte postale pour
les voyages et la carte grise pour la
voiture